we're closing out your line like this
[Music]
we got a lot of tricks for you guys
today
[Music]
me
think about you all the time
[Music]
it's friday we're starting early for you
guys
[Music]
think about you all the time
higher higher
[Applause]
[Music]
let's radiate
party real let's go
[Music]
we got a lot of secrets today
if you came in the game with your squad
i want to see you guys line up and do
some remotes for me
[Music]
straight away
higher down
[Music]
it's friday
everybody asia europe all the way to
america
[Music]
the weekend starts right now
i need your help on this one right here
on the count of three i want everybody
jumping on this one we're gonna try it
out together
[Music]
everybody jump jump
new york city waking up
[Music]
[Applause]
higher ground
[Music]
[Applause]
again
you were the only one who made me feel
something
i see those remotes
let's go
[Music]
let's bring the rain
it's a storm tonight
worldwide
oh
[Music]
it's a worldwide party right now
we got something special for you guys
[Applause]
watch out from above
let this disco ball
[Music]
let's go
i see you guys in morocco
[Music]
egypt
i like that dance let's go let's go
let's go
this is diploma
higher ground party where yeah
[Music]
gonna count it down one more time you
guys ready
[Music]
on the drop one
two
let those disco balls come
[Music]
so
we're doing an extra long set for you
guys tonight
[Music]
if you're in the plaza i need you guys
to come down for this one right here
i need everybody to come down right now
to the main stage
it's about to get crazy let's go
[Music]
this one drops we're gonna get trippy
let's go
[Music]
everybody
higher ground
[Applause]
[Music]
if you have the most emotes in this game
tonight's the night to show it off right
here
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
i see you jumping i see
[Music]
[Applause]
i see everybody riding those rockets
let's go
we're gonna take it to paris one time
you ready
[Music]
we're gonna make it sexy
lazy lakes
that's what he said
party royale let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe you can't go to the club
[Music]
maybe you're locked down but right now
it's time for everybody to party
[Music]
i see you see me stacks
all the way to misty meadows let's go
[Music]
oh my god game
it's hot in this game let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
we're taking this jungle right now
[Music]
all my gamers worldwide
is
[Music]
it's more like a swamp it's more like a
swamp though
i need a boat
let me get a boat
[Applause]
somebody needs to pull up on a boat to
the main stage right now
[Music]
a yacht
you pull up with a boat i'm gonna give
you guys a million v bucks right now
let's go
[Music]
my soccer players
main stage
foreign
and
[Music]
we got something special for you guys
right now
[Music]
we're gonna drive it out real quick
you've been diplomatized
[Music]
one
two
let's do the confetti
we got some breakdances out here
[Music]
italy's awake italy's awake
spin line
moscow we see you guys
[Music]
i wish i could be with you guys all over
the world touring this summer but this
is as good as it gets and this is better
than it gets
party royale
[Music]
let's say we get to party all over the
world one club let's do this
[Music]
bye
me
[Music]
i see america's waking up
i'm gonna take you guys to brazil real
quick
[Applause]
world worldwide
we got five minutes left
[Applause]
i need everybody to come from the plaza
we're gonna set it off together higher
ground
party royale
you ready
[Music]
bring that rocket back
um
[Music]
it's been an amazing summer with you
guys
djing on fortnite
millions of people all over the world
checking out
[Music]
shout out epic games
we got one more for you guys thank you
guys so much
looking for me
[Music]
oh yeah
we're gonna descend together
[Music]
we miss you guys
let me get something special right now
here we go here we go
um
[Applause]
[Music]
this was amazing thank you guys shout
out epic games
for tonight all the people that showed
up all summer long partying with us
my name is diplo i'll see you guys soon
hopefully
[Music]
[Applause]
bone
ground iron
ground
higher
[Music]
is